would you mind just doing a quick Test
please before you come in testing for
covid thank you wearing masks a daily
pandemic routine for all of us but for
around half a million immunocompromised
people in the UK like Imogen it still is
yeah all good any infection for her even
now is potentially life-threatening
she's worried about another fixture of
the last three years disappearing the
official NHS covert app
people like me the fact that we still
need to think about being so careful and
our lives are still so much on hold
absolutely we'd like things to be
different but they're not covered hasn't
gone away and stopping recording it and
trying to ignore it isn't actually a
public health strategy
the app is estimated to have stopped
millions of infections this is a
different phase of the fight
Nicola is one of the only patients on
this covered Ward with a virus as a main
cause of illness she has diabetes which
makes her particularly vulnerable three
years ago I was frightened this thing
was a monster and I don't think people
are as frightened of it now it's not as
it was a couple of years ago vulnerable
groups are being offered booster
vaccines this spring but the NHS has
largely shifted away from firefighting
to planning for a virus that's here to
stay
when we see outbreaks or perhaps new
variants of covert come along I think we
do still have to be particularly
Vigilant at those times because it will
have an impact as we've discussed on
Staffing and how we are able to look
after people in hospital so this is the
past that I used at Junior when wooden
doubles Tanisha only ever wanted to be a
professional tennis player
this was her a month before she got ill
now she is among two million people in
the UK suffering from long covered and
at just 21 she's been forced to retire
I'm grieving my life I'm grieving myself
because
that loss of Independence
is is so is so unsettling it's so it
makes me almost want to cry because
I don't know if I'll ever be able to
live a life where covert and long
covered isn't at the back of my mind
kovid is not as dangerous as it once was
but as the last of the pandemic
Protocols are removed its potential
impact shouldn't be underestimated or
forgotten
oh she's Joshi Sky News